السودان تشهد اشتباكات في العاصمه الخرطوم
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
خاصه حول النقاط الحيويه الاستراتيجيه
وافاد مراسل الجزيره بان هناك اصوات اسلحه
ثقيله وتصاعدا لاعمده الدخان وتحليقا
للطائرات الحربيه بمحيط القصر الرئاسي
ومركز الخرطوم واضاف مراسلنا ان سلاح الجو
السوداني نفذ طلعات في الخرطوم بحري وسرعت
مضادات طيران التابعه للدعم السريع للرد
وبشان معارك يوم الاحد قال الجيش السوداني
في بيان ان الموقف كان مستقرا في جميع مدن
البلاد لا من بعض المناوشات واعلن القبض
على ما اسمهم قناصه من الدعم السريع
من جانبها تامت قوات الدعم السريع الجيش
السوداني
والجيش السوداني باتباع سياسه الارض
المحروقه حسب تعبيرها بقصف جميع مدن ولايه
الخرطوم بطيران والمدافع وقالت قوات الدعم
السريع في بيان ان اتهام الجيش للجان
المقاومه بمسانده قوات الدعم السريع هو
استمرار في حمله الاكاذيب وعلىنت قياده
قوات الدعم السريع ان 130 فردا من الجيش
السوداني بقياده لواء سلموا انفسهم بسبب
حصار القياده العامه للجيش